be archived one may envision rooms and
shelves stacked with boxes and cartons
of old stuff and yet for those who are
patient enough to dig through it the
archive provides the precious
opportunity to touch the past to feel
and learn from the experiences of once
living people who now seem dead and
buried deeply in the archive but what if
there was a way to bring the archive to
life the world is thinking wrong about
race this country insists upon judging
the Negro because it does not know what
if one could make it breathe by his
lowest and most vicious representative
speak an honest straightforward exhibit
and even sing to us so that the archive
becomes accessible to everyone
what would performing the archive looks
like a performance that is not simply
based on a true story
but one that allows us to come face to
face with things we thought were once
dead and buried this is what at Buffalo
a new musical we're developing is all
about using collections from over 30
archival institutions at Buffalo
performs the massive archive of the 1901
pan-american exposition the first
World's Fair of the 20th century held in
Buffalo New York
now if you've heard of this fair it
might be because this is where the US
President William McKinley was
assassinated for nearly seventeen years
I stayed inside the gates in the archive
of this fair not only because of that
story but because of a real
life-and-death racial drama that played
out on the fairgrounds here in a place
that was like Disney World the Olympics
carnivals museums all in one there were
three conflicting displays of what it
meant to be black in the United States
the archive says white showman presented
a savage black origin in the form of 98
western central Africans living and
performing war dances in a recreated
village called darkness
Africa and across the street a happy
slave life in the form of a hundred and
fifty seven black performers picking
cotton singing and dancing minstrel
shows in a recreated Antebellum
attraction called old plantation as a
response the black Buffalo community
championed the third display of
blackness the Negro exhibit co.design by
African American scholar WB Dubois it
curated photographs charts books and
more to show black Americans as a high
achieving race capable of education and
progress when I first encountered this
story I understood from my own life
experience what was at stake
to have members of the African Diaspora
see each other like this for me as the
child of immigrant parents from Ghana
West Africa born in the American South
raised in Manhattan Kansas and and
having attended the same elite school as
Dubois I could see that the Buffalo fair
effectively pitted the black northerner
against the southerner the educated
against the uneducated and the
african-american against the African and
I wanted to know how did these three
distinct groups of black folk navigate
this experience unfortunately the
archive hid answers to questions like
this underneath racial caricature
conflicting information and worse
silence still I could hear musical
melodies and see dance numbers and the
rhythms of the words coming off the
pages of old newspaper articles and
learning that this world's fair had
music playing everywhere honest
fairgrounds I knew that live immersive
spectacular musical theater with the
latest technologies of our time it's the
closest experience that could bring the
archival story of the night to no one
fare out of boxes and into life
stories like tani and Henrietta a
husband and wife Bob will do all in love
could become at odds over performing
these cool minstrel shows while striving
for their $5 a week dream in the old
plantation attraction like African
businessman John T V from present-day
Togo who must outwit the savage rules of
the human Zoo in which he has become
trapped and stories like Mary Talbert
wealthy leader of black Buffalo elite
who must come to terms with the racial
realities of her hometown the dominant
race in this country insists upon
judging the negro by his lowest and most
vicious representative like old
plantation and darkest Africa instead of
by the more intelligent and worthy
classes when Fair Directors ignored Mary
Talbert and the local dock Buffalo
communities request to participate in
the fair newspapers say that Mary
Talbert and her club of educated
african-american women held a rousing
protest meeting but the details of that
meeting even down to the fiery speech
she gave were not fully captured in the
archive so a buffalo takes the essence
of Mary's speech and turns it into song
we must we are unanimous we must we are
unanimous we've got something to show
we're gonna teach a lesson in Buffalo it
would benefit the nation to see our
province emancipation colored people
should be represented in this
pan-american exposition it would benefit
the nation to see our role since
emancipation they made a great mistake
not to appoint someone from
[Music]
my Mary toddler successfully demands
that the Negro exhibit come to the fair
and to have the Negro exhibit in Buffalo
means that the musical must tell the
story behind why Dubois co-created it
and why Mary and the black elite felt it
was urgently needed the world is
thinking wrong about race they killed
Sam hoes for who they thought he was and
long men like him every day more Negro
men like him taken apart and after that
that red ray we could never be the same
red rain
[Music]
cut across my desk the very Dane Sam's
hands were laid to rest in words alone
withstand the law is unjust and words
alone withstand the violence
Oh No
[Music]
[Music]
who has read the books are not resistant
to salsa
[Music]
the crisis has multiplied our people are
something
something must change Apple reveals how
the United States today stands at
similar crossroads as 1901 America just
as the name of Sam holes filled
newspapers back thin today's media
carries the names of Oscar Grant
Jacqueline Colt Trayvon Martin Sandra
bland and to many others the 1901 fairs
legacies persist in more ways than we
can imagine
Mary Talbert and the National
Association of colored women started
movements against lynching and the myth
of black criminality just as
black-winged today started black lives
matter and some of the same people who
fought for and created the Negro exhibit
including Dubois came to Buffalo four
years after the fair to start the
Niagara movement which set the
groundwork for the creation of the
n-double a-c-p
it's not just black folks who had a
peculiar experience at the night - no
one fair an official handbook informed
pear goers please remember once you get
inside the gate you are a part of the
show performing the archive in at
Buffalo allows audiences to ask
themselves are we still inside the gates
and are we all still part of the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]